[Music]
on a clear dark night we can all Marvel
at a crystal Sky brimming with
stars and Beyond what we can see with
the naked eye powerful telescopes
confirm an expansive Cosmos chalk full
of galaxies and stars and swirling
clouds of gas and dust and planets and
comets and asteroids but here is the
amazing realization telling the mass and
energy of everything in the cosmos that
we can see accounts for less than 5% of
what there is the rest more than
95% is invisible to even the most
powerful telescope
imaginable because it is all
dark the dominant ingredients in the
makeup of the cosmos do not emit or
reflect light and so have been named
dark matter and dark
energy but if we can't see the dark side
of the cosmos how do we know it
exists well scientists have deduced the
Dark Universe indirectly by its effect
on the universe that we can see and
among the scientists who were the
earliest champions of a cosmic dark side
was James pebles one of the most
influential cosmologists of our time
pees has played a critical role in
numerous cosmological advances including
the discovery and decoding of the cosmic
microwave background
radiation a decisive tool for analyzing
the Dark Universe and refining
cosmological Theory contribution
that earn peoples the
2019 Nobel Prize in
physics welcome Jim thank you so much
for being
here so so many people who go into
science or
mathematics often tell stories that they
knew from when they were like four or
five years old that this is what they
wanted to do but I gather for you the
journey was a little bit more circuitous
than that true true um I think as a as a
student in high school I was
unsatisfactory not because I was at all
rebellious but because I was a dreamer I
didn't pay much attention to the courses
I passed them but I didn't participate
in any sports activities communal
activities um I was a dreamer and and
was that like by
yourself yes bl by myself in books or um
well you know my father was handy with
his hands and he liked to build things I
like to build things I like to mess
around with with
electric motors transistors
Transformers
um and uh because I was not paying
attention I went into
engineering which I did because I knew
Engineers built things and I knew I
built things so that seemed right I mean
you say you were not paying attention
meaning I didn't ask anyone I just
entered ah the University of Manitoba
okay um where I discovered at the
engineering department that what I
really liked were those courses in
physics so I transferred and it was the
best thing I could have done right and
was there a particular course in physics
that really made it clear that that's
what you wanted to do more important I
think it been important one Professor
which is what you need uh who took an
interest in me taught a good course that
taught me a lot about physics and then
he declared uh he had been a graduate
student in physics at Princeton uh 10
years earlier and he decided you should
go to Princeton so all right can I went
and it was wonderful of course it was a
big fish in a small pond becoming a
little fish in a very big pond but I
survived
yeah and I gather at that time at
Princeton you had two really iconic
individuals who are starting to think
about gravity but in very different ways
John Wheeler is the one who you know we
in the theoretical Community know well
but of course Bob Dicky yes was there as
well can you give a sense of their
different approaches well you you you
summarized it well to John a Wheeler
Johnny uh general relativity was such a
beautiful theory that it was almost
certainly a good approximation to
reality Bob dicki uh certainly
understood Theory well but he was a
brilliant
experimentalist he had spent 10 years
after arriving at Princeton doing
laboratory what might call Quantum
Optics he decided that gravity
experimental gravity had languished
since the 30s when difficult experiments
were done but was technology that was so
much more crude than what could be done
with the electronics that came out of
the second world war so Bob decided to
set up a program of tests of gravity
physics including the old classics but
do them better with modern Electronics
now like oos experiment for example yes
uh many others testing active and
gravitational Mass equivalence yeah very
clever experiments so uh
it I am a theorist but his work was much
to my taste so I started with him he is
the one who said you might consider
looking into the expanding universe
theory I did and where do you think that
came from from from Dicky was was he
just starting to think about cosmology
and applying general relativity whether
was it air um not in the air U although
Bob and and John were were quite close
and familiar they had very different
worldviews John well Einstein's general
theory of relativity is so elegant to
Bob it's a theory and you don't trust
theories until he'd been tested and so
he's he was looking for tests all
kinds he had a quite a quite a large
group of graduate students doing lots of
very interesting experiments um and of
course gravity figures large in the
theory of the expanding universe so he
became interested in it that's why he
suggested I started working in it and
did he have a specific idea I gather yes
he did yep yeah
um he decided that
uh of course you had that old problem
what was the universe doing before it
was expanding yeah uh one idea that
people had discussed it was a bounce
Universe collapsed bounced I guess
Tolman was pushing that Tolman was
pushing that it's a natural notion Bob
noticed um and worked out the elegant
physics of that in a collapse it's going
to be thermodynamically in irreversible
going to produce a lot of entropy which
would be largely in radiation so this
universe that's now expanding would be
expected to contain a sea of radiation
that radiation would be expected to have
a specific spectrum that is to say the
intensity at each wavelength uh
uh he uh had invented during the war of
microwave radiometer a device capable of
very sensitive measurements of radiation
uh he suggested to two of his young
people in his group David Wilkinson and
Bri and Peter R why don't you build a
radiometer to see if there's anything
there and he said to me so casual remark
why don't you think about the
consequences of this experiment whether
a detection or non- detection right now
A non- detection would have been
interesting yes oh yes and of course it
has implications you have a real
challenge if the universe uh in the very
early stages of expansion were called
yeah because the protons would fuse to
make heavy elements and that's not the
way our universe is made most of the
Barons they already hydrogen and helium
so of course there's a way out you
postulate to gener
neutrinos and so that that's a
possibility to consider I of course
worked on that but turns out um the
radiation is there and it has been
wonderfully instructive now the
discovery of the radiation is itself an
interesting sociological SL physics
story oh yes oh yes you know it goes a
long way back already in the early
1940s people observed Interstellar atoms
and molecules by the absorption of light
from stars behind them uh the molecules
cause absorption line the atoms cause
absorption lines a discovery was that uh
the molecule CN
Cyanogen carbon and nitrogen stuck
together is absorbed observed in
interstellar gas in emiss in in
absorption and startlingly it's observed
in absorption in the first excited level
remember in quantum physics energies are
quantized in an isolated system it was a
puzzle why should uh the Cyanogen in
interstellar space be in an excited
level right one possibility slightly
mentioned maybe there's a sea of thermal
radiation that's pushing it up to this
first excited level
then again uh when people started at
Bell Laboratories in northern New Jersey
started thinking about Communications by
microwaves which had to me the rather
unhappy consequence of producing those
cell phones that I see our students at
Princeton University walking around
staring at rather than admiring that
beautiful
campus but among other detrimental
effects among others um
1959 engineers at babbs developed very
sensitive detectors to use in
Communications they found that the
receivers were receiving a little more
noise a little more electromagnetic
radiation than they could account for
that for that was a dirty little secret
at Bell Telephone Laboratories in
northern New Jersey and this is before
penius and Wilson Oh yes right five
years before um it remained a PR little
secret until penus and Wilson two young
people from
physics
1964 decided Well we ought to find out
the source of this
radiation they work very they're to be
credited for refusing to give up the
search for the source of this radiation
and you know I'm I'm impressed that the
the their their their bosses allowed
them to keep
going this in a commercial yeah research
laboratory but one you know B Labs at
that time had had had had had they had a
monopoly on the telephone now they were
controlled and so they couldn't charge
too much money but they had a lot of
money a lot of Revenue yeah and they SP
resulted in Freedom right oh boy
transistors it's just a very impressive
place anyway they allowed these guys to
keep going
pens and Wilson also did something very
sensible they complained why can't we
find the complaints actually eventually
reached
Princeton where
uh Bob dicki had as I said suggested the
two of his young young members of his
group uh build a radiometer of the kind
that b bobit had invented during the war
to look for this radiation so the two
met and the recog recognition wow maybe
this is maybe that noise in microwave
radiation came from the early Universe
now often the story is told that the
next step was a telephone call
yes um so we well we were having lunch
in Bob's office back lunch uh phone rang
uh Bob
answered uh I could see David
Wilkinson's ears pop up mention of well
sources
uh radiation leakage through the an
through the joints of the of the
microwave pant
microwave
channels um and it was pretty clear and
then Bob turned and said well we've been
scooped you know I'm often asked what
was our what was our emotional reaction
to that yeah and what was your emotional
reaction to that you have to bear in
mind this experiment was a blind search
in the dark no guarantee that anything
would be detected of course it was not
detected that's interesting but still
um the fact that Bell had shown that
there is something there to be further
studied experimentally and to study
theoretically that's my job to find this
implications was very exciting so uh
it's often said well you must have been
chagrined but certainly not me that was
a real exciting moment how about the
more
experimentally oriented members of the
well they had something wonderful to do
so David Wilkinson spent the entire rest
of his career yeah and I spent the
entire rest of my career just following
Bob's suggestion now you and penius and
Wilson the two two groups I gather
agreed to write two separate papers
right one on the experimental discovery
of the microwave background radiation
and one more on the explanation and
prediction from a cosmological
perspective followed the the first being
the the detection the second the
implications now when you look at the
experimental paper I've always been
taken by the fact that there's zero
mention of anything but the experimental
detection not even a word about
cosmology was that agreement or did
penius and Wilson just want to State the
facts and and not muddy it with any
potential theoretical interpretation
that's probably a good motivation but um
I don't know I never discussed it with
in
fact Bob dicki directed the papers I
don't know whether he suggested or
whether pen Wilson realized you made a
very good point let's not money in the
water right right now of course history
shows that the Nobel Prize was awarded
for this discovery to penus and Wilson
some have suggested
that there could have been a more
generous spreading out of the prize
perhaps to Bob you know so what's your
view of that well I was totally
disgusted um I I deeply respect the
Nobel Prize and the Nobel committee
those people work really hard to get it
right they work really
hard but this was this is a brainless
move it it should be penus Wilson dicki
dicki invented the instrument he
suggested the use and he told the Bell
people what they may have found it was
obvious
um how how did he how did he take that
did he show any sense of well I remember
he was a little chagrined a little
chagrined you should understand uh the
people at the Nobel committee uh work
really hard yeah but they're people they
make mistakes right right now the other
interesting part of the story is that in
time you and and others recognize that
there'd have been even earlier
intimation
of these ideas from gamma and and alfur
can you just give us a sense of that
backstory well so
gamov had the deepest physical intuition
of anyone I've ever encountered just
dazzling uh I maybe it's inevitable that
such brilliant intuition must go along
with a certain dislike of
authority so uh gamov you know during
the 30s he was one of the leading
authorities in nuclear
physics at the time uh shortly after the
uh World War II that is relevant he was
finishing the Third Edition of his book
on nuclear physics why wasn't he part of
the effort at lelos to develop the
atomic bomb everyone else was there it
was his refusal to take take seriously
in the notion of security yeah so but
brilliant character in
1948 he wrote a paper with with Ral
elfer uh and uh since
beta since Alpha and Gamma look like the
second and third letters of the Greek
alphabet he put in by hand the name of
Hans beta to write a paper famously
known Alpha Beta gamma uh the paper
assumed a cold start to the expanding
Universe it's totally
wrong right later in that same year his
intuition Hit Upon what was totally
right the notion of a hot Universe with
many of the physical considerations that
were then fleshed out by di by centuries
of by many people
uh it's so funny that in the first of
the papers where he got it right a hot
big bang he mentioned the alphabeta gam
paper and saying due to a numerical
error but it wasn't a numerical error
this is gamov right I don't care about
that old paper uh anyway gamov got many
of the ideas right but because he was
such a flighty person and because
shortly after two brilliant papers in
1948 he streamlined the idea down to a
theory that was just not
logical so um his theory dropped out of
sight yeah it wasn't forgotten by
everybody but me I a physicist knew
nothing about this so I had to start
from
scratch gamma Theory didn't didn't make
its way into the textbooks yeah in
particular you know the wonderful series
of theoretical physics by oh land
land they they had they had a third of
their book on classical theory of fields
is G relativity Theory ironic because it
is then was not a theory that was at all
well tested it did it included the
notion of the expanding universe but
they introduced a footnote this may be
all wrong because the universe may not
be homogeneous right they didn't mention
um the hot big bang they didn't mention
gamov and so I didn't know about gamov
so that was eventually the connection
was made by the time of those two papers
you mentioned our paper has references
though I have to admit among those
references was Alpha Beta gamma I hadn't
done the homework to recognize that that
paper is
wrong I let it get in there yeah and the
and but there's also an alfer Ralph
alfer paper with Hermon on the uh CNB
and predicting as a 5 degree background
temperature that was their great
contribution yeah following gamma's two
papers in 1948 they pointed out that uh
in this Theory you would expect that the
uh universe is filled with a near
uniform sea of radiation at a very well
well determined temperature around 5° or
maybe 8° or close enough yeah to be
consistent with what was later
discovered
yeah incidentally I mentioned the
Cyanogen temperature it was
2.3k 2.3
Kelvin alha 5 Kelvin the observation
2.32 75 right right wow no it's amazing
yeah and so we now had evidence that
this thermal background is there which
is giving us evidence of the hot big
bang approach to cosmology but as you
said you didn't stop there this is
really the beginning because now you
have this Relic from The Big Bang you
can start to push further so what was
the the the next step in trying to
understand this radiation what it means
the very first Next Step the key step is
this R does this radiation really have a
thermal spectrum that is to say you give
me one parameter a temperature I'll tell
you the intensity of each wav link yeah
attempts to check that were very
difficult because you had to get above
the atmosphere to reach the peak of the
radiation and getting above the
atmosphere and doing experiments is
really difficult yeah the result was
that during the 70s there was a
persistent indication of an anomaly that
the Spectrum isn't quite
thermal that was a horrible that that
really made me uneasy because it's easy
to imagine that the early Universe
was energetically mixed up enough to
produce radiation enough to have
Disturbed the Spectrum if it did that
then the distribution of radiation
across the sky
is giving you a measure of some complex
process that was a horrible thought it
wasn't until the early 80s when John Ma
and
others flew the definite
experiments that showed wow it's exactly
almost exactly thermal that
meant that the small departures from an
exactly uniform thermal C was telling
you about the nature of departures from
uniformity in the m
distribution suddenly you had the
prospect of a Precision test compute the
evolution of the mass
distribution predict its present
properties and then measure them and
that was really key because you could
make these computations very reliably
they're just linear perturbation Theory
and that means because you can also make
Precision measurements that you had a
wonderful tight test of theory against
observation which is very new in a realm
of cosmology which which so it made a
convincing case that we are on the right
track right and so just to review that
key idea you're saying that small in
homogeneities in the matter distribution
they would be centers around which
additional mass and a kind of snowball
gravitational effect would accumulate
giving rise to galaxies so this is
essential to understanding how these
structures exist the word snowball is is
a is a hazardous Point galaxies are
complex yeah and so their properties
aren't really a very good test of the
expanding Universe it's the slight
departures from uniformity in the
radiation and in the large scale
distribution of the galaxies that you
can compute reliably and you can measure
pretty reliably and my goodness they
agree and in fact there's a a beautiful
graph which shows the anisotropies in
the microwave background radiation
against the measurements well here's the
uh this is the black Body Curve this is
what made me feel
good and early 1980s is that's John
Mather is there a second one that
shows ah interesting that uh there were
many attempts to measure the intensity
of this radiation as a function of
wavelength two
people drove experiment that got it
right John Ma's experiment was proposed
to NASA 15 years
before the
measurement beautiful work required but
enormous effort to make that measurement
in the Year John Mather submitted a
proposal to NASA herb gush lead author
in this measurement flew a
rocket herd gush is a Canadian
University of British Columbia more more
modest funding at the time in Canada uh
he couldn't fly a rocket that is
adequate to carry the shielding that was
needed but he flew it
anyway he made the first attempt at the
measurement of the spectrum from outer
space 15 years later and many failed
attempts shall I mention an example of
the horrors of Rocket measurements why
not solid fuel rocket it carries up the
rocket the instrument
explosive bolts release the instrument
it goes ahead and leaves the rocket
behind but some of the solid fuel in the
rocket didn't burn CAU fire after the
instrument package had been released and
the rocket ran ahead of the instrument
package and sprayed it with noxious
chemicals oh gosh it's a tough life you
have to be tough yeah uh eventually
though within months the two got the
measurement both would have made the
case that it's thermal
radiation John Mather received the Nobel
Prize for that measurement well deserved
well deserved yeah herb gush got the
Deep respect of his colleagues but
nothing more so is that another example
of the Noel committee trying their best
but perhaps not getting it yes thank you
yeah you know I'm from Canada and so a
certain shavinism
yeah maybe apparent here so this is the
curve that
establishes the black body spectrum that
any of you viewers here or in digital
you take a basic physics class and
statistical mechanics thermodynamics you
learn about this curve a a box at
thermal equilibrium will have this
particular Spectrum right and then
amazingly the deviation from perfect
thermal Spectrum was the the next major
result that allowed one to really as you
say do Precision tests and you
understand it was the absence of serious
deviations which would have meant
serious deviations in from non from
linearity in the early Universe would
have made uh the whole thing very
impossible right but there it is you can
you can be quite sure the early universe
is quite tranquil slightly disturbed by
growing departures from moment geneity
now to take this to the next step you
introduced into
cosmology another idea which has been
with us ever
since dark matter in particular cold
Dark Matter so can you explain the
trajector in your thinking that leads to
that step the Galaxy distribution is
quite
clumpy that's fine gravity would
naturally draw things together and make
a clumpy distribution of something was
almost exactly smooth but to move around
the matter to make it that clumpy would
seriously disturb the microwave
radiation so how do I understand that
the microwave radiation is so very
smooth well the matter is so clumpy the
way out had to be an ad hoc guess that
most of the matter in our universe is
not made of the Barons electrons protons
neutrons of a standard Theory but rather
something invented ad hoc dark matter
let it be cold to begin with because
that's simple it's the first thing to
try and also it keeps the pressure low
presumably that's right so it's easier
to compute yeah and uh ask yourself the
question would this scenario work the
idea is simply that uh as gravity is
drawing matter together bionic matter
together it will in radiation but if
most of the matter is not bionic and
does not interact with the radiation
then it won't disturb the radiation very
much so already in
1982 I had computed the first the DI the
quadriple moment I had a prediction it's
sort of fun to
realize how long it took to check that
prediction what couple of decades yeah
but but it was found
then of course we get to
this
um the bionic matter and the radiation
in the early Universe strongly interact
because the temperature is high enough
to strip atoms of the electrons the
electrons scatter off the radiation
strongly enough to tightly couple them
the electrons scatter off the
ions tight strongly enough to couple
them so ions electrons and radiation act
as a
fluid which has a pressure which means
uh if it's Disturbed from uniformity it
will oscillate like a
wave that oscillation like a
wave means that the final Mass
distribution and the final distribution
of the radiation uh are uh
computable if the if the departures from
uniformity are small so you can use
linear Theory
and here uh are dazzling
results recently obtained The Wiggles uh
you understand of course resonance which
is a key thing if I had a bottle I would
blow across his top and I would make a
tone which is set by the boundary
conditions in the
bottle the university has boundary
conditions it must start smooth and it
must end these this coupling when the
radiation Falls to a temperature of
about a th000 Kelvin when the electrons
can combine with the ions and that lets
the radiation free to move to move and
the matter free to move so you can
compute all that uh in this graph uh The
Wiggles are the results of those that
resonance lucky and unlucky modes modes
that grow and modes that diminish uh
that can be computed the solid curve
assumes particular values for parameters
such as the mass density in Dark Matter
the mass density in bionic matter uh the
abundance of helium which
matters um and
the solid curves are adjusted to fit
those
constraints the data points are data
points they're not at all well measured
in the radiation at the very small L
value and L is like a wave number it's a
reciprocal of a length so that's large
length scales where we don't have a very
good sample of the universe because you
could only see so much of it the rest
spectacular agreement and even more
spectacular to
me the distribution of galaxies of large
scales is measured in a very different
way so you have different
theories matching data obtained in very
different ways and getting a consistent
story it's really
dazzling shockingly dazzling that a
calculation that really can be done on
paper and pencil you know can can yield
something so precise about the nature of
the universe at large yeah nature seems
to operate that way yeah and uh it gives
us very important
point you don't trust a theory until
you've had it tested and what you just
saw is a really demanding test that it
convincingly establishes the hot big
bang general relativity Theory as a
remarkably good approximation to reality
now there was another anomaly that you
were paying more attention to than most
at this time regarding the expansion
rate of space in fact I've read in
various places that people would find it
irritating when you'd bring up this
issue at times but it turned out again
to be right so maybe give us some ins on
what that was all about right so
Einstein another spectacularly intuitive
person and maybe better self-controlled
than
GMA uh Einstein decided in first he
introduced his general theory of
relativity in in
1915 it was a spectacular intuition um
so beautiful that many people accepted
it but it it was not based on much
empirical evidence on the other hand so
then two years later he decided Well I'm
going to try to apply this Theory to the
structure of the universe for reasons
that no one has ever explained to me he
decided that the universe is uniform in
the large scale average why did he
assume
that Simplicity Simplicity uh he found
that this universe uh would not stay
static of course it's it's obvious that
the universe is static it's not
changing of course it is changing
uh but to keep the universe from
collapsing under Gravity he introduced a
term he added to his his field equations
of general relativity so it it was got
in urine the name the cosmological
constant that added term um Einstein
later emphasized was added only because
he had to fit the observations he did
not realize there was an observation
that the universe is
expanding as soon as he learned that he
decided
the cosmological constant must
go but uh now in the 1990s the early
1990s uh it was becoming very clear that
if you didn't put the cosmological
constant into Einstein's field equations
then uh then the Motions of the
galaxies indicated a mass density that
is quite large small small small
compared to what you would expect from
the rate of
expansion at the time people were so
impressed by the Simplicity of
Einstein's field equation and of a
homogeneous near homogeneous Universe uh
and so impressed I think by the two
facts that the cosmological constant is
disliked by Einstein and because if you
accept standard quantum physics then the
Z Point Energy of the electromagnetic
field would add up to an absurdly large
cosmological constant the only solution
something caused the cosmological
constant not to be
there that was very
convincingly convinced many people
surely there is not a cosmological
constant but I was doing uh studies of
how the galaxies are distributed how
they're moving and to make that story
fit I had to assume a mass density
considerably less than was required by
this universe without the cosmological
constant so I proposed adding the
cosmological constant that did offend
people yeah um I remember one young
person very capable now a great
scientist saying you're only doing this
to
annoy and do you know the
old Lewis Carol
be be be to your little boy whenever he
sneezes he only does it to annoy because
it knows it teases
and and I I must admit that I kind of
enjoyed going to conferences in the
1990s and pointing out the evidence for
the cosmological because I knew it
teased right and just from the physics
standpoint the cosmological con with the
right sign would yield an outward push
that's exactly that would assist the
expansion that would solve the problem
right so now in that me in that um image
you saw of the oscillating the
computation it it has a cosmological
constant that um well it's needed and
what size were you suggesting back then
were you giving a numerical oh I was but
I don't remember these things instead
it's a dimensionist measure what is the
ratio to the pionic density
and I don't even remember that was it
like sish or is that a
hint U I adjusted it to fit the
measurements okay which were only the
mass density is the essential point and
it was I think reliably nailed down to a
factor of two right so it was and then
the beautiful thing is
1998 when the observations from the
distant exploding Supernova yeah gave an
answer that showed there was a cosmos
that produced that produced the um Nobel
Prize yeah um just a magnificent result
that people had been trying to achieve
ever since the 30s people knew it would
be a critical measurement yeah um but
you know if we' had only that uh it
would have been unsatisfactory how do
you know that Supernova at Red shift 1
are really very similar to Y the year
2000 give plus or minus one the first
detections of these oscillations were
found and were found to require a
cosmological constant so you found that
more convincing yes really because it's
a it's simpler simple to
compute uh and whereas the evolution of
supernova is impossible to compute right
so I was I was not convinced by the
Supernova I deeply admired it those
people did a great thing yeah but as a
practical matter it was the radiation
that uh who his anisotropy was detected
that convinced me now does it bother you
or maybe that's the wrong way of framing
it does it make you wonder about the
fact that these dark entities the dark
matter the dark energy they're kind of
patches yes they are in order to make
things work they're not something that
we've directly detected that's right
bare patches and where do you come down
on that is that do you view them as sort
of a temporary fix or are they the
answer that ultimately will be directly
confirmed I can't believe there they're
more than a temporary fix got to be more
interesting has to be a wonderful
challenge for the next Generations learn
how to make a more realistic model for
the nature of matter in the universe
dark and light and so the failure to
detect Dark Matter over many decades now
yes where where does that leave you on
thinking we just have been looking the
wrong way or it's a more exotic species
or yeah uh nobody ever guaranteed that
we could make a any sense of the
universe around
us and I've often wondered why were
people so sure that the Universe
operates in a rational
way you see equally early examples of it
um T ta o brde 2,000 years ago had a
theory for the Motions of the
planets it was it was an ad hoc Theory
circles but yet he managed to get very
good predictions yeah uh and
I guess he wasn't particularly worried
about the fact that well why are circles
so
very you do what you can yeah so far we
have not found any flaw in the use of
dark matter and dark energy cosmological
constant and so we'll stick with it but
we certainly lust after hints of failure
of the standard theory that will hint to
a better a still better Theory because
it will have have more interesting
properties for the Dark Sector would you
be surprised if say 30 50 years from now
the Dark Sector has been replaced by
some new theoretical idea some new force
of nature something of that sort right I
I certainly don't expect that the be the
main outlines of the standard Theory we
have now are wrong yeah but in detail I
think they got to be wrong and who knows
maybe tomorrow you'll hear news of
detection
um or maybe you will never know never a
guarantee that we can solve all the
problems of that are opposed to us yeah
for sure so in terms of anomalies with
the standard Theory there are a variety
of hints of things to come right one of
which is the so-called Hubble tension
yes when you measure the expansion rate
of the universe basically in two
different domains early Universe later
universe and try to extrapolate they
don't quite meet yes do you think that's
a big
clue number one I'm impressed that they
almost meet you're comparing what
happens in the universe Lo recently and
in the remote past that they should
agree at all is startling to me but of
course they don't agree that maybe
because of systematic errors it would
have to be I think in the local Universe
measurements uh systematic errors may be
the culprit
uh or maybe and this what I'm hoping for
this is a true anomaly which is telling
us there's something observably wrong
with a standard Theory so let's look for
what it is and of course let's also look
for more anomalies and maybe if we have
enough we'll see how they all fit
together you think James web Space
Telescope observations are going to
resolve this particular anomaly only
know if you try yeah
right so it's still very much up in the
air but but one can hope as we go
forward and it's good to be looking in
lots of directions by lots of ways yeah
you as you've gone forward to refine
cosmological
Theory scientists you the community at
large have taken on problems which in an
earlier age reviewed as we'll get to
that at some point but we're not ready
to yet and among those for instance are
questions that inflationary cosmology
has tried to address this idea that in
the early Universe there was some phase
of Rapid expansion driven presumably by
some energy that mimicked a cosmological
conent of a very large value in the
early universe and drove everything
outward there's controversy now about
inflation although I think some of the
inflationary proponents may get angry at
me for calling it a controversy but but
there are differing opinions right now
the inflationary structure where do you
come down on
this I have to respect these beautiful
theoretical ideas after all Einstein's
general theory of
relativity based on almost pure thought
has wonderfully successful I got to
respect that and I've got to respect the
possibility that inflation is in the
same line but I don't trust it until we
have some evidence and unfortunately
it's very difficult to get evid
empirical checks so that early on on so
I say yes let a thousand ideas Bloom and
meanwhile wait and hope we can think of
something that contest these ideas now
now one of the particular issues there
there a number but some people bristle
at a fairly generic quality of
inflationary models which is they make
our universe not the only universe so
the inflationary fuel that drives a
rapid expansion it's not exhausted
by the expansion in our realm and the
leftover fuel roughly speaking gives
rise to other Big Bangs in other
Realms now for someone like you who
wants things to be tested which of
course is the way science is meant to
progress does the idea of other
universes seem nutty to you or or are
you willing to sort of allow for a
tested Theory to make untestable
predictions um it should be done but how
much how how seriously should we take
the ideas
yeah I'm quite comfortable to hear about
the
Multiverse um but I might mention one
point yeah we talk about eternal
inflation but Eternal inflation is very
clear can be Eternal into the future but
it can't be internal back in the past
yeah we run into these logical problems
as well as imp iCal problems and we pay
attention to them and do you think we'll
ever be able to deal with the issue of
the past I mean the question that I'm
asked most frequently both by students
and by the general public is okay you've
got this big bang idea okay maybe
inflation but what got it started right
why was there the inflaton field you
know why was there any expansion in the
beginning at all we're waiting out of
our subjects you think so yes and with
subject are we waiting into
speculation many many possible ideas but
you think that it will resist scientific
explanation do you think that there are
questions of that sort that will simply
be beyond the reach of the methods of
science I I dislike definite statements
so I say it certainly looks
likely that we will not be able to
answer all
questions and how do you feel about that
is that just the way it is or no one
told us we could find answers to all
questions I'm I'm amazed at how well
we've done yeah and I'm sure we'll be
doing even better there's a great future
ahead of you all in in in physics it's a
good subject uh but you're not going to
get all answers that's
just to me obvious so the big one that
live nits asked a long time ago why is
there something rather than nothing that
is among those presumably I I don't lose
sleep over that question so as we turn
to the Future there are a number of
missions that are planned we've we've
made reference already to obviously the
discovery of the microwave background
radiation then the confirmation of the
black body Spectrum with Kobe and also
the Canadian experiment that that you
described the anisotropies that came
from Kobe and then we got a lot more
information from w map and and from
plank MH we have James web up there now
doing remarkable work what of the
upcoming missions are you excited about
well we've reached a point in this
subject where there are two lines of
Investigation first you can do
measurements that have already been done
much better and you should do that
better you perhaps will find that what
look like close AG green ment of theory
and experiment Isn't So Close maybe
there's an anomaly that's very important
to be done but you know in the rush to
advance the science you do tend to leave
behind little Oddities that you feel
well we'll get to that later yeah and we
don't there are in cosmology many
questions that remain open that are a
little outside the general line of
approach of the big experiments to do a
big experiment you got to be pretty sure
that you know the
answer and to find deviate find big
missing pieces of the puzzle you have to
step back and start thinking and maybe
do a small
experiment I'm I'm I'm I Harbor The Hope
and I'm working on it that there are
puzzles that were left behind in the
rush to advance that are pointing us to
issues that are going to teach us how to
do better in cosmology do you have any
that you can share with us as some final
words in our conversation here of where
you're putting your attention at the
moment do we have a photograph of a
galaxy do we have a photograph of a
galaxy imagine that there is one because
we will make it look that way in the
digital version of the program okay a
beautiful one is named Messier 101
nearby face on spiral
wonderful
uh it's a gorgeous image do you see the
blue patches that's where groups of
stars are formed relatively recently
among the groups of stars there are some
that are much more massive than the sun
they are far more luminous they're hot
blue that's what makes the blue patches
you notice red patches that's where
these massive stars have produced enough
ionizing radiation that they produced
patches of plasma in the plasma the
dominant ion is hydrogen its
recombination line is a big fat line in
the red notice a glow of yellow toward
the center that glow extends across that
whole galaxy it is a light of stars
similar in Mass to the sun astronomers
have shown that in our patch of our
galaxy there are at least as many
planets around stars as there are
stars this is showing us a system
that we can never reach it's it's 10
million miles 10 million light years
away uh in which there are some 10 to
the
9th planets on which all sorts of things
of wonderful things are happening that
we the human race will never see that's
one cautionary remark I like to explain
the other is the Fantastic spiral galaxy
the evidence is from observations of
other galaxies that this galaxy is thin
like a discus all the way to the
center that thin discus is not obtained
in numerical simulations of the
formations of galaxies within the
parameters of the standard hot big bang
cosmology it's a real deep puzzle why is
this thing so thin and why do the spiral
arms go all the way to the center and
I'm might point to the enlargement on
the left from the Hubble Space Telescope
instrument you see how the spiral arms
extend almost to the center where
there's a bright spot that's a million
solar masses of stars that's a big
number but trivial compared to the mass
of this
Galaxy 10 to the 10 10 the 10.5 in Stars
uh in our galaxy there's a massive black
hole in the center is there a massive
black hole in the center of this galaxy
I'm really hoping J wst turns its power
to that little spot and determines
whether or not the G stars are moving in
such a way as to indicate the presence
of a black hole in the very center we
don't know where black holes come from
that's one big puzzle yeah the other is
uh we don't understand why the mass
around the black hole is so darned close
to smooth and moving so slowly that it
can form a spiral arm a beautiful set of
puzzles right here before our very
eyes and do you anticipate Insight on
that from numerical computational
studies that are more refined in
understanding the Dynamics they've been
working on it for years and very refined
and so far no one has found a Galaxy to
my way of thinking that matches the
properties of this one that means
there's something we've left out of the
computation my bet is
what is it what did we leave out well no
it's up to
you you need to discover what we left
out of this
Theory great challenge for all of you
one final question before we end
here one recent result from the James
web Space Telescope is that early
galaxies seem to not conform to what we
would have thought from the standard
cosmological scenario they're they're
brighter at earlier times and more
massive and more massive what do you
what do you think about that well I I
it's another example of the fact that we
don't really understand well how
galaxies
form and so that another valuable clue
but do you have any nope no guesses of
where that's going to go again another
challenge for all of you both live and
digitally who are watching this it's
been a fascinating conversation Jim
thank you so much for joining us please
join me in thanking Professor Jim
[Applause]
[Music]
p